elle a 34 ans est en politique depuis
l'âge de 27 ans sanaa marine devient la
plus jeune première liste de l'histoire
de la finlande et dirigera le parti
social-démocrate à la question comment
vous sentez-vous d'avoir les clés du
château à 34 ans elle répond je n'ai
jamais pensé à mon âge ni à montjean ans
dit m mais surtout aux raisons qui m'ont
poussé à faire de la politique
ancien ministre du transport elle
succède à entériner qui a perdu la
confiance du parti après sa mauvaise
gestion d'une grève postale qui a duré
deux semaines
une situation qui s'est aggravée avec la
grève des transports et de l'aviation
à un mois de noël né en 1985 elle a été
élevée par un couple de femmes aux
origines modestes
une famille arc-en-ciel dit-elle où la
justice l'égalité et les droits humains
était le fondement de son éducation
camarades dit-elle joignons nos forces
et travaillons ensemble pour une société
viable sur le plan économique et
environnemental
et voici ses camarades cinq jeunes
femmes à la tête des cinq partis
politiques qui forment la coalition de
centre gauche
une fois de plus la finlande semble être
le pays d'avant garde
c'est le premier en europe à avoir
accordé le vote aux femmes en 1906 ici à
0 2 les gars qui sera du canada - rien